Hey youtubers it’s charlie.
This week I asked you all to submit arrow
and flash related questions since so much
happened.
We got to meet Rashe al ghul’s other daughter
and learn all about the cast of the flash.
Grant gustin even trolled us with a picture
of himself wearing the suit.
No joke.
He posted this to his instagram.
I ended up picking 5 questions from my Arrow
review and 5 questions from my flash preview.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I do arrow Q&As every week after new episodes
air.
Be sure to subscribe to get them!
Since there’s no new episode for a couple
week’s I’ll try to think of something
fun to do next week.
Q&A time, let’s go!
Question Number 1 7th Element (no avatar)
asks Do you think Oliver could ever take Deathstroke
alone considering the Mirakuru?
If anyone stronger than Deathstroke reveals
themselves, how will Oliver stand up to them?
Two part answer, not in a fair fight he can’t.
The mirakuru gives Slade almost limitless
stamina, so he could just keep oliver at a
stalemate until he got so fatigued he’d
start making mistakes.
He’d only be able to get slade by tricking
him or fighting dirty.
to the other part of your question, that’s
why they don’t have people with crazy superpowers
on the show.
It would just get ridiculous, there’d be
no way oliver could fight darkside by himself.
The justice league however...
Question 2 Aayush Patel asks As Flash and
Arrow TV shows are existing in the same universe,
what does it mean for Arrow's villains?
Will we be seeing super-villains with actual
super powers?
And if so which ones do you reckon are likely
to appear on Arrow?
I think I mentioned in my flash video, most
of the stuff on arrow including the villains
will stay on arrow and the flash stuff will
stay on the flash.
They’ve already cast villains for the flash
show.
The flash villains have superpowers, and since
grant gustin has the speedforce I think that
show will do actual superpowers before arrow
does.
The character of the green arrow is a normal
person, so mostly you’ll see him fighting
other normal non-powered villains.
Batman in the movies is the same way.
Human vs human.
As opposed to superhuman vs superhuman.
It just makes more sense on a conceptual level.
Question 3 Callum Butler (no avatar) asks
I know this programme is normally at 9 on
sky 1 when does it return to the UK ?
The most recent listing I saw said SkyHD would
be airing episode 10 Febuary 20th, so bet
on new episodes each week after that for the
rest of the season.
There are 23 episodes total.
Question 4 - Aymen Krist asks we saw sex scene
in the end between oli and sara ..what do
you expect from their relation ?﻿ (deborah
nugyen - ‘ships)
I expect that
it won’t last.
Dramatically it’s much more exciting to
see a hero rise than to see him just sit around
and be happy.
In order to rise you have to be struck low
by a villain.
So something will happen before the end of
the season to break them up.
I don’t know what that is, but I’m expecting
it.
Question 5 - Sunny Tyler asks Birds of Prey,
So will The Huntress will be back?
And what about
The Oracle?
Birds of Prey is episode 17, it comes right
after the suicide squad episode.
Huntress is coming back and she’s full on
nutters.
Remember how during season 1 oliver tried
to stop her from killing.
She’s only gotten worse since then.
Her real life Helena persona is gone and she’s
just that avatar of justice now.
Felicity will be the oracle character.
Huntress will be trying to kill more people,
laurel will get in the middle and sara as
the canary will try to kill her to protect
laurel.
Obviously huntress isn’t going to die, but
the birds of prey arc is going to start with
them at each other’s throats.
Literally.
In an interview the showrunners said that
they’re taking a multi-season arc with the
birds of prey.
So that kind of implies that caity lotz will
keep on being the canary in season 3 which
is awesome.
That same interview says the same thing for
deathstroke.
So slade will be back next year too.
He’s slowly becoming the deathstroke from
the comic books.
and here’s where the flash questions start
Question 6 Shelby Larson asks My friend wants
to watch The Flash but not Arrow (I don't
know why)...
Do you think it would be possible to only
watch The Flash?/ Only watch Arrow?
Or do you need to see both to understand what's
going on?﻿
You’re friends are silly, but yes, the flash
season 1 will be designed so that anyone can
jump on without reading the comics or knowing
anything about the characters.
Tell them to drink the arrow kool-aide.
(sideways mouth)
Question 7 Mitchell Knights asks What will
the flash suit look like?
The new 52 version.
Or very very close to it.
Geoff Johns was pretty up front about them
going full on with the tv show.
No holding back.
No idea how the suit will work in execution.
I would assume he’ll befriend the vibe character
at star labs and they’ll help him design
a suit that will work at superspeed.
Question 8 Ralph C asks about the race-bending
for the west characters and a possible wally
west character.
I don’t have any problem with them changing
characters when they find actors they like.
They didn’t do it just to do it.
Usually if they find an actor they think is
perfect they’ll just alter the character
to match.
As for Wally West, he hasn’t been cast but
since they’re being pretty faithful to the
comic books I would say he’ll show up at
some point.
Given the age of Barry Allen though, he’d
probably only be a little kid.
Question 9 herodannyphantom asks do you think
Barry will have his own team like Oliver's
team arrow.﻿
It will be like Arrow season 1, it took oliver
most of the season to open up to diggle and
then later to felicity about being the vigilante.
And now in season 2 there’s roy and the
canary.
So the same thing will happen with barry.
First he’ll probably start on his own, then
one of his friends will find out, like detective
west or Iris and then the two of them will
keep the secret from the other friend.
Then that friend will find out and you’ve
got your team.
It’s pretty cut and dry.
Question 10 Summer Bradshaw asks Hal Jordan
Green Lanter meetup, other Geoff Johns whatnot
like Gorilla Grodd and the rogues gallery?
You had a ton of great questions so I’m
mashing up all my answers.
No green lantern, but since it is geoff johns
doing a lot of creative, you should keep your
eyes peeled for easter eggs in the background.
As for the other villains like gorilla grodd
and the rogues gallery, they’ll do the arrow
thing where one episode at a time you’ll
see them eventually.
Gorilla grodd feels big enough to be a season
2 kind of thing.
Rogues gallery, yeah definitely sometime during
season 1.
For reference, danielle panabaker will probably
be the first supervillain he fights.
If she gets her powers in the first couple
of episodes.
Rick cosnett’s professor zoom character
will probably be more like slade.
Hide in the shadows till the end of the season.
This week’s bonus question also comes from
summer (same person) other spinoffs Young
Justice, Suicide Squad.
A bunch of you have asked about spinoffs,
officially only the suicide squad has been
teased, but now that we have roy and slades
children will surface eventually, yes young
justice will be discussed more.
But if either show ends up happening it probably
wouldn’t be until flash gets a third season.
So we’re talking like 2016.
Which is actually the year superman vs batman
is getting released.
So maybe young justice in the same year we
get a mini-justice league movie.
It could totally happen!
Thanks so much for submitting questions everyone.
This was a lot of fun as always.
Remember arrow is gone for about 3 weeks so
I’ll think of something fun to do next week.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Walking Dead is back sunday.
Look out for my video after it airs.
Plus there’s a special game of thrones video
happening too.
Right now click here to learn all about the
flash tv show and click here for my arrow
playlist.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!